in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to rotate a point about another
point which is not the origin so you
learned previously how to rotate 90 180
degrees 270 degrees counterclockwise
about the origin but now what we're
going to have is a new center of
rotation we're going to go through three
easy steps that you can apply I'm going
to try to show you why it works in this
first example and then we'll do two
other examples where you can practice on
your own if you like to get some more
experience and then at the end of the
video I'll show you where these 90 180
degree and 270 degree rules Come From if
you want to want to understand that more
deeply so for the first example we're
rotating Point P which is at 2 comma 5
about the center of rotation one three
if we're rotating at 90 degrees
counterclockwise that's going to be like
this
so what we want to do is the first step
is to subtract the center of rotation
from point P so what we're going to do
is we're going to take our point which
is 2 comma 5.
and we're going to subtract the center
of rotation 1 3
and 2 minus 1 comes out to 1 and 5 minus
3 comes out to 2. now you're probably
saying well why are we doing that right
well imagine if your center of rotation
is like your new origin okay so I'm
drawing in a dash X and Y axis there you
can see Point p is really like right one
up two see how we have one comma two so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to apply our rotation rules in
this case 90 degrees counterclockwise XY
becomes negative y x so the way I like
to think about it is you switch the X
and the Y
and you make this new x value the
opposite sign okay that's how I like to
think about it you switch the X and the
Y the new X's becomes the opposite okay
so now we're at negative 2 comma 1. so
from this perspective you can think
about this is like left two up one and
you can see how we've rotated that 90
degrees I'll even draw on some more
dotted lines see that right angle but
then what you want to do is you want to
add back the center of rotation to this
new Point negative 2 1. so if we do that
our Center of rotation is one comma
three negative two plus one is negative
one and one plus three is four and look
at where this point is right here you're
at left one up four and that's exactly
where
the point is located so three easy steps
let's try another example see if we can
practice this one on your okay example
number two see if you can pause the
video and try this one on your own we're
rotating this point one negative 4
180 degrees counterclockwise or
clockwise doesn't matter because 180 is
a half rotation half turn about the
center the new center rotation which is
at zero comma two right here so go ahead
and try that one now if I was going to
do it what I would do is apply these
rules the first thing would be to
subtract the center rotation from our
points I'll just label these steps so
step one we take one negative four
and we subtract 0 comma two so that's
going to give us 1 minus 0 is 1 and
negative 4 minus two is negative six now
to try to understand this you know a
little bit more deeply we can think
about the center of rotation as like our
new
origin right so kind of have a a new
origin point right there and when we're
subtracting 0 to okay what that's
basically doing is it's taking the
center of rotation and it's moving it
back to where the origin
is okay where our normal origin is and
so then what that allows us to do is to
apply our rules just like we normally do
when we're rotating about the origin so
you can see this point one negative 6
from the perspective of this new center
rotation we're at right one
down six see there's our Point as if
that was the the origin right so then
step number two is we're going to apply
the rotation rules now with 180 degrees
all we do is we keep the X and the y in
the same order but we make them the
opposite sign okay so what that's going
to be is now for step two this will
become negative one this will become
positive six so the signs flip
so negative 1 6 what does that mean well
basically what it means is that from
this Center of rotation this new point
if we were to go left one up six
that would put us right here so you're
basically turning let me see if I can
draw a dotted line here
you're doing like a half turn and you
can see this point is
ending up right there rotating or
pivoting about this new center of
rotation right but then what's going to
happen for the last step is we're going
to add back the center of rotation to
that point so for step three we're going
to take negative 1 6 we're going to add
back
zero comma two so negative 1 plus 0 is
negative 1 and 6 plus 2 is 8. and you
can see that that's where our point is
located from the original 0 0 point the
original origin left one up eight now
why are we adding back that Center of
rotation at the very end there well
remember originally we subtracted it
okay so that basically brought this
point to the origin now when we add it
back we're putting it back to where to
where we started right so just like a
translation like if you're sliding
everything down to which is what we did
here originally then we rotated then we
had to move everything back up to to put
it into the uh you know to the final
position there so let's try one more for
example okay see if you can pause the
video and try example number three this
one we're rotating Point P negative two
negative five
270 degrees counterclockwise about the
new center of rotation here negative one
comma two this is the point you're
pivoting or rotating about so see if you
can do that problem if I was going to do
it notice I didn't even draw a diagram
here I'm just going to follow the three
easy steps here so the first step
subtract the center of rotation from the
point so we're going to start with
negative 2 negative 5. and we're going
to subtract our Center rotation negative
1 2 that comes out to negative 2 minus
negative 1 is like negative two plus one
so that's negative 1 and negative 5
minus 2 is negative seven okay good so
now we want to apply the rotation rules
for 270 we switch the X and the Y so we
basically interchange them and we make
the new y value the opposite so what I
mean by that is I switch these
so it's going to become like negative 7
negative 1 but I make this new y value
the opposite so that becomes a positive
one last step is we want to add back
that Center rotation to this point so
we're going to say negative 7 1 plus the
new the center of rotation negative 1 2
gives us our final location of our point
so negative seven plus negative 1 is
negative eight and one plus two is three
and you got it okay the last thing that
I thought we could do together here is
just try to understand you know where
these uh rules come from these 90 degree
180 degree and 270 degree
counterclockwise rotation rules and so
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to take a simple point and you might
want to do this on your own as well just
to kind of visualize but see if we take
this point
for one what I like to do is just kind
of draw this as a triangle so visualize
if I make a triangle like this
okay and so what we're going to do now
is we're going to rotate this 90 degrees
so imagine if I held my finger right
here at the origin and if this was on a
sheet of paper if I actually turned it
90 degrees a quarter turn what would
happen is this x-axis would turn and
match up with the y-axis right so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
this triangle I'm going to rotate it and
so that's going to look like
this now
okay so can you see it so this point
here will actually end up right here and
what is the location of this point it's
negative one see left one up four so
when we rotated 90 degrees
what happened well you can see that the
X and the Y coordinates switched but
this new x coordinate is the opposite
sign so see we switch the X and the Y we
made that new X the opposite right now
let's say if we're going to rotate 180
degrees if so take this guy here 180
degrees imagine if I was holding my
finger right at the origin here and I
just to Pivot or turn about this point
it would be like a half turn so
basically we would be rotating a half
turn like this and you can do this on a
sheet of paper to kind of visualize and
so this would put us somewhere right
about here our triangle
okay and so you can see that this point
notice how this is like a straight line
turning at a half turn so this point is
at negative 4 negative one now what
happened here from our original point
the X and the Y are in the same location
four and one it's just that the signs
are the opposite so see X and Y negative
x negative y same order just the
opposite side and then lastly if we were
to rotate 270 degrees that's going to be
like a three quarter turn so I'm holding
my finger at the origin I'm turning my
paper 90 180 three quarters of a turn
that's going to put us right
here
and so there's your point and that point
is located at one negative four
what happened from this Original Point
well you can see we switched to X and
the Y right and it's the new a y That's
the opposite so see accent y are
switching see y-axis but it's that new y
That's the opposite so that's how I like
to think about it maybe that's helped
for you too
if you like the way that I explain
things and you want to learn more about
Algebra 1 or Algebra 2 college algebra
I've got video courses
um links in the description that you can
check out my courses for sale and if you
just want to support what I'm doing here
with these instructional videos on my
Mario's math tutoring YouTube channel
consider joining the channel as a
channel member so for a few dollars a
month you can help support this content
and I really appreciate it if you want
to see more about rotations I'll put a
link to a video right there that I did
previously check that out if you want to
get some more practice and I'll see you
over in that video